welcome to Hannity the midterms they are
only 15 days away and tonight we are in
beautiful Scottsdale Arizona where in
just a moment we will be joined by
Republican Senate candidate Blake
Masters any Blake fans here okay
gubernatorial candidate Perry Lake will
join us uh who is now who is now opened
up a three-point lead against Democrat
gutless cowardly Katie Hobbs in the
latest for thousand polls Hobbs who is
currently collecting a paycheck as
Arizona secretary of state has only
shown up to work a grand total of 19
days in the last six months I wish I had
that job uh she didn't even enter office
for the entire month of April and August
and meanwhile Hobbs is not exactly out
there working hard on the campaign Trail
either she has participated and this is
so unfair to you the hard-working
citizens taxpayers of this state of
Arizona zero debates she refuses to
debate in both the prime Primary in the
general election Katie Hobbs would
rather hide in her basement bunker just
like her Mentor Joey Biden is probably
asleep during the show anyway Corey Lake
meanwhile has offered to debate any
place any time anywhere Hobbs can't seem
to muster up the courage take a look
why have you refused to debate your
opponent she wants to go head-to-head
toe-to-toe with you with a moderator
look it is honestly ridiculous that
somebody who has based their whole
campaign on these lies that are intended
to dismantle our democracy that somehow
the problem is that I won't give her a
bigger stage to do that why not
challenge her though in a public forum
I'm just curious
as far as I'm concerned the debate about
debates is over I'm running my campaign
the way I'm running my campaign I'm
going to continue to make the case
directly to voters at worst it could
come off as you're scared to step on
that stage and at best you're not
willing to confront we're in a new era
where Sometimes some politicians are
seen as bullies and we've been taught
since we were little kids you got to
stand up to a bully you won't you
understand how that might come across
how do you make a case we want to send
you to fight for us but you won't even
step on stage I have stood up to this
bully for the past two years and that's
and arizonans have seen that and I'm
going to continue to do that continue to
do that no the real reason is she's
gutless and she knows that she would be
unable to defend her radical positions
let's go through them for example she
supports no limitations on abortion
whatsoever that would mean you can have
an abortion up until the very moment of
birth that would be called infanticide
you might recall during the pandemic she
opposed the deportation of illegal
immigrants and her only plan to address
the Border crisis is to provide amnesty
for illegal immigrants she does not
support a border wall she does not
support Federal funding for more border
agents but they do like IRS agents the
Democrats they like them a lot in fact
she really doesn't seem to care about
the Border crisis at all actually
telling a local paper quote it's
ridiculous that we're talking about this
as a core issue in the governor's race
no that would be a primary issue now
meanwhile during her time in the Arizona
State Legislature Hobbes regularly
opposed tax cuts but she did support a
500 million dollar sales tax increase
and also voted to hire more than 100 new
state tax collectors she's also faced a
variety of scandals listen to this
including allegations of racial
discrimination from a state senate
staffer it resulted in Arizona taxpayers
shelling out three hundred thousand
dollars on behalf of Katie Hobbs and
that's not all multiple former campaign
staffers accused Hobbes of fostering
what is an emotionally abusive work
environment and last spring nearly 80
percent of her initial staffers they
quit they didn't want to work for her
and by the way if you now support or
have ever voted for Donald Trump Katie
Hopps hates you in fact on Twitter she
called Trump supporters quote Neo Nazis
now Katie Hobbs is a classic far left
keyboard Warrior behind a computer
screen she is an outspoken bully but in
real life she is a cowardly incompetent
self-absorbed narcissist [ __ ] that has
never been more apparent
and during this town hall
simple question take a look
what have you learned
specifically learn from the Latino
community
oh that's a great question
um I don't necessarily think about it
that way in those terms that my
sister-in-law she is uh Latino and uh
her family I love hanging out with them
and practicing my espanol
Arizona wouldn't be Arizona without the
what the Latino Community brings
so there's not one specific lesson you
could share with me follow them
[Music]
uh
it's one third of the state yeah yes
absolutely I I
I mean I think there's there's many
lessons
now the people of Arizona they deserve
better and thankfully there is someone
who is willing and able uh to work hard
every day and stand up for the people of
this great state and it is definitely
not Katie Hobbs